hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to donut County you are
going to love this game trust me
you see this face it's a face you can
trust this game is like if you were
playing Katamari Damacy i'ma see Donna
say o da ma mama say mama sama mom who
saw cada Maradona see except it's all a
big hole like it's a big hole in the
ground like that's the whole point of
the game it's a big hole in the ground
well I mean not the game itself it's not
a big hole in the ground you're trying
to make a big hole in the I'm not making
a lot of sense but hopefully it now
makes sense now that it's been cut up
properly and had some of the stupid
remove doing it anyway we're gonna play
this game
it's about holes and that's it so if
you've seen the movie holes you probably
got a good base of it mirrors home
Mira's house I can't even read that
properly either way ami told me about
this game and I just had to play it oh
oh look at you Oh Mira when are you
coming into work I'm bored what is this
duck Duck Duck
[Laughter]
quiet BK shut up you loser I'm dead I've
died please have some respect
Lowell why are you dead ducks the
honking man woke me up again at the honk
of dawn honking unbelievable
don't worry I'll revenge you also I
don't know why I'm talking to a raccoon
but okay be careful dude this guy really
honks yeah whatever come to the donut
shop and stop feeding your dog bread he
needs bread live BK he's a certified
loaf okay I'm leaving in five minutes
bye okay bye
sorry loaf oh that's a finger all right
it's the honking man get outta here honk
Oh honk Oh chunk Oh uh-oh
hello oh my god you're a goose hi
honking man
yeah so this is the game yeah you better
watch out you better not pout oh it's oh
god it's so satisfying so there's the
game you know how I said it was like
Katamari Damacy that's because you got a
hole and you just make things fall in
the hole honking man you just go ends
with nut Oh honking man you about to say
goodbye my friend oh yeah you cannot run
away oh you think you can run oh you
better be concerned I don't know how I'm
doing this but I I just gotta just gotta
tell you man uuh fit in the hole come on
get in the hole honking man honk down
that hole goodbye and goodbye forever I
suppose and that's all there is to it
you don't need to worry about that
honking man never coming back here again
honking man ain't gonna bother nobody
ever cos honking man is very dead all
right the donut shop
hey are you doing there ding-dong okay
I'll walk right in ah dude the honking
stopped did you actually just do
something to the honking man duck yeah I
did you don't worry about him he's dead
extremely dead I just delivered him a
donut okay
Lowell well I guess it distracted him
honk uh-huh okay guess what I'm level
nine now I don't know in what but I'm
level nine do you impressed Wow no not
at all cool yeah I know that's extremely
boring you don't get it at level ten I
can earn my quadcopter all right sick
yeah whatever Congrats okay duck we're
gonna buzz around like kings okay see
you soon BK all right what have you say
six weeks later well that's a long time
for honking man to go missing you'd
think that his family might be worried
about
Oh Mira how Oh God
how could you smash my quadcopter you're
tearing me apart Mira who cares about
your stupid quadcopter how could you
destroy the entire town you're tearing
me up I raccoon 999 feet below don't ah
this is a flash forward
oh so you're what you're saying is what
you're saying is my little experiment
with the holes magically appearing in
the ground is what destroyed the entire
society hey I see honking man over there
hey monkey wow that sounded rude but I
just met it like as a cute name a
nickname
whoo you're so cute that whatever what
do we got here
hey the whole gangs here BK I've never
done anything duh I'm kind
oh my god what do you use that stupid
app to open up holes all over the town
and now we're all stuck on the ground
everything here looks fine to me
except my quadcopter I'm the victim will
someone back me up here
Coco BK it's obvious that you did it I
got swallowed by a hole right after I
ordered a doughnut from your shop what
does that have to do to do with Mira
smashing my quadcopter Potter what
happened to your son oh oh oh my sweet
pup and boy oh he must still be up there
somewhere
oh I thought oh okay all right then
Potter's Rock left click to deploy hole
well that is the motto with which I live
my life
click all over town deploy my hole all
right here we go
I'm gonna click beat a hole there we go
uh-huh as normal everybody what what was
that
oh that's underground when it Oh
ah no that's me that's that's the hole
getting bigger okay all right
god you're precious cargo give me that
Cup
all right give me the skull and give me
the suitcase yeah give me the box
it would go well look I'm at the top
left
oh it's like a let's play yeah lady you
better run away this uh this ain't good
what's happening here today yeah you
better oh no oh this is probably
terrible this is probably the worst
thing that could ever happen to this
society here we go taking it anyway
excuse me lady
oh you doing pottery oh that's so nice
that's so nice you don't need this water
do you or this clay no you don't need
those is Crate nope number two kraid
more like it look look at the Sun that
must be the Sun hey lady you should
probably pay attention your butt you're
about to get hold oh I can't wait to
make this pot for my son he's gonna love
it and then falls to her demise I guess
she's not dead so what does it matter
oh no it's just hey pop word up it's so
cute
oh hey I used I use that tool ever that
in there that's a clever mechanic oh
this is so satisfying someone post this
to are satisfying there you go come on
scooch in there I know you can fit chair
come on I know you can do it I know you
don't want to do it but I know you're
gonna do it anyway look at this oh [ __ ]
well you're - you're so big I can't fit
you just yet but I can fit you guys hole
buddy dope well whoa I doesn't sound
good whatever just happened to the audio
then again everything I'm doing right
now it seems to be
oh well the music seems to have taken a
turn for the more somber and now it's
quiet so that's yeah you bet oh smart
well anyway you better run away because
it's about to go bad how does this
raccoon not think this is just a
terrible a terrible - OH
oh that poor lady is on fire oh well I
just fell luckily I landed on my hip so
that was replaced long ago as long as I
don't light on fire suddenly I can see
my spot and then she dies oh oh oh and
now I'm cooking the Sun a lot goodbye
see ya oh that's not good
ah well that would be what some people
call a problem don't worry I'll clean it
up you don't need to worry about nothing
that wool right bye donut oh oh hey okay
all right I got peace o donut oh boy
oh this is so cool I just love the
feeling of it it's just so I mean it's
it's eminently destructive so I guess it
appeals to that sense inside of me
that's like kind of all about that sort
of thing but honestly it's satisfying
and cool and fun oh that's clever - oh
there's the screaming Oh No
[Music]
oh I see oh that's so funny okay you may
think there's loot inside because it
says barrel but it's full spiders free
house don't let it get wet go in here if
you want to be yelled at by coyotes
coffee rules it burns your tongue it
makes you go to the bathroom protects
yous from cows do not try to watch
cotton candy in the pool this tip will
save your life I get it this reference
to that video a raccoon tried to wash
cotton candy in a pool you can make your
own bones at home by murdering people
okay drinking from this is like kissing
a dog but not as fun
it's a rock don't try to eat it okay
just a normal stuff that you fill with
mud Potter and puppy used to live they
used to live period sometimes you can
find good ideas inside how many birds
are you willing to fight for a bag of
chips easy to knock over check the
bottom for bugs I don't know it's a pot
usually a good sign there's trash nearby
spins about around for fun another pot
Wow a hiding wall great for peeking
someone bought this sign in case you
were thinking of buying it yourself
that's to bless you see spies it doesn't
help you catch them though makes your
eyes cry when you stick your
child-safety cactus climb inside for a
free ride that's so nice thank you I'm
gonna get that quadcopter have a garbage
day I will I will have a garbage day 999
feet below donut County hey y'all still
mad at me for the whole killing
everybody thing I just wanted to
surprise pup with a doughnut sniffs Norv
oof humph
now he's floating away in heaven oh no
he's not
if you got swallowed first how do you
know pup is in the balloon this story is
full of holes Oh your brain is full of
holes and so is the entire town thanks
to you
just doing my job wait I mean not true
I'm innocent
wait puppies in a hot-air balloon I saw
a hot air balloon float by my ranger
station you saw pop which way was he
heading which way was he careening to
his device I don't know I got distracted
I just ordered a donut nice I get hungry
when I'm anxious anxious about what
believe it or not snakes
oh I think with all the animals here
then that's a little racist right a
little bit of racist huh okay I'm
deploying my whole boop my there's my
hole all right well don't worry about
your snake problem I'm gonna take care
of those snakes an ting gonna whoa oh
he's spooked oh he don't want it oh he
don't want none well if he goes face
first in its not really gonna help him
much so I guess I guess that's his
problem not mine
what are you this is like a nice nap for
this poor snake and then God just God
they're sweet that means there's snakes
down there with them that's probably not
a good thing they should probably watch
your yikes
boo oh jeez it's like it's the struggle
that makes it more disconcerting and
kind of feels like I'm doing something
wrong here oh yeah and well they're all
gone now all right cool
all right well oh these poor chickens
these [ __ ] are gonna get it get my hole
get in my hole I shouldn't be screaming
this out loud but go oh no oh not
sneaking
that's dog that's wrong I don't want to
be uh I don't want to be like I don't
wanna be like I'm gonna be a bearer of
bad news or not oh okay well I just
horned I just horn this before chicken
oh well all right then listen listen
listen listen this snake is not
dangerous if you don't provoke it look
look look oh wait here eat this here
chicken eat eat this worm come on come
on slap you bap well you want to fight
yeah you ain't got ups welp there goes
the tooter whop whop whop whop really
slapping this [ __ ] around here I do this
every time I get out of the shower all
the guys can relate to this okay let's
see what else again there slap OH
Oh No we've reached optimal snake danger
I don't think I can fit anything down
here while I got this snake BAP go go
we're gonna thwack this there we go oh
no snake danger overload oh oh oh what
did we await a minute I didn't know that
snake danger levels made more snakes
that's just like like a prophecy coming
true
okay bye chickadees okay
goody chick chicken snake anis next next
wheel sayonara sayonara goodbye okay
goodbye
fairly well all voice this is probably
not the best thing oh boy yeah well well
well
when we get this on the other side well
okay let me get this tire her just the
tire please okay my worst fear Oh pit
hole with snakes okay it's one thing to
own a chicken but two chickens that's
two things a large mug for dirt lovers
you're always on the wrong side of it
the wire allows you to grab the egg and
pet the chicken gloves for your car wood
jail for freaks plastic bird that scares
you live spaghetti awfully lively
spaghetti a live spaghetti with the
ability to hate if your chicken doesn't
have a swing Wow no one knows what it
says only monsters don't press the
button tells you what temperature the
snakes are snakes go to die here that's
sad it's shaped to look like a big bird
tune in to spy on the government do not
get spotted well too late I think I did
oh well whatever have a garbage day hurl
me in a dumpster yet no there's
something we can all relate to I think
are you guys still peeved about the fact
that I didn't fill the town full of
holes
Lowell sounds like you should be
thanking me for solving your snake
problem wait
so it was you who opened up the holes no
I'm just saying whoever did do that was
totally doing you a solid and way he
likes dick jokes too much he's probably
a really cool and nice guy did anyone
else see pup yep I saw up pup I'm Jim's
wrong my face it's kind of like a
bowling ball or a Kiwi has gotten a few
spots on it if you stare too long into
my face you kind of get possessed buddy
that are waiting just to crawl inside
your soul that needs to get out your
entire brain doesn't help there I'm
sitting right in behind the fire so that
the flames lick away at all hope and
only feed the despair that's inside your
mind when you look inside me anyway with
my telescope you mean my telescope my
face also kind of [ __ ] up oh I think
about it a lot of very self-conscious
about it you know but I don't let it get
me down the voices inside my head keep
me company anyway that's what I stood my
telescope where did you see him well me
and pepper were feuding again so I moved
my trailer the mid-river he took a
liking to this bird
yep a bird made for liking I was
admiring this bird so I saw was hit with
a hunger so I ordered a doughnut by way
of this doughnut County app then the
hole came anyway what the hell dog
that's dog that's not how you dog oh
that's dog you okay there dog dog you
all right that's not are you dog soup
absorb please all right face down in
there look I'm sorry dog that down one's
mine and dog no dog run run dog I'm not
gonna get you dog nothin till last
anyway dog you can't hop away from your
foot okay I guess you can hop right into
your face well there you go Doug I'm
real proud of you really really stuck it
through Oh what happens with water what
what does water do oh oh that's some
kind of clever there oh that's oh that's
oh that's nice I like that oh that's
good get down oh that's good I like that
okay I like it dad okay I'm gonna get
you I'm gonna get you suck up this water
here you want some more water man you
thirsty
yeah you're real thirsty I guess it
would be a big mistake to suck you up
first gotta get rid of all the holes I
love the music - how this games so cool
this is a charming it's just a charming
you know what I mean guys it's just a
goddamn charming okay well goodbye oh
can I not have that oh do I have to get
to keep Adam OGG oh okay now oh now I
get you well anyway your mom's gone
again I didn't get to get the mug the
mug broke I almost caught the mug
portable outhouse half up nice guitar
has the word forever car didn't do it
well maybe not free sled press the
buttons on top to select your flavor
extremely terrible way to keep your
fries safe you can tell a fish your
secret so they won't remember anything
tennis balls only grow in hard-to-reach
places tell me how do you get eight Bob
bird tell me okay I don't know I didn't
get the cup I didn't get the Wow so are
you saying you're like in love with a
bird yup
is that legal BK it's not about the bird
it's about the bird mirror it is about
the bird
you're hopeless dude oh is that the bird
oh we're all hopeless now coyote I
thought you moved away to the desert
ah dad BK must be targeting folks who
are down on their luck
coyote you're the original owner of the
donut county donut shop right yep
buddy went out of business when the
raccoons moved into town I sold the
raccoons a shop and moved out to the
desert oh no I'm sorry coyote can't be
helped
the Coyotes laugh is like us a country
tune I made a modest living selling
vegetables suppose it was my way of
giving back to the
folks Oh are you ever gonna come out of
that tent there you know where are you
growing this corn oh hey oh they're
going there buddy
um don't mind me just your Donuts
arrived so that's uh that's something
forward to you don't need to worry about
nothing like yeah there we go
give me the corn oh yeah I'll take that
corn boy just rock in the back I'll take
that and this plant there and now take
the fire there we go good bye oh oh oh
we're on fire again that's Oh jeezum so
Go Go popcorn that's so smart I get it
no I get it
no that's dog that's clever oh that's
frickin clever
well that's clever as [ __ ] okay sorry
you're gonna you're gonna okay there you
go okay I'll get the popcorn I guess I
don't know if I need to get the popcorn
but I'm gonna get the popcorn there we
go yo homie noise there we go there we
go there we go there we go there we
gotta go and then I saw the biggest hole
I ever done did say alright and how I'm
dead okay hey wait I wanted that sign oh
oh you need to do you need to get him
last oh [ __ ] my tit okay same someday
everything will be made of corn why
waste a good card on anything besides
hotdogs rocks were given to us by aliens
this is probably the worst place to pour
milk and ooh yeah probably try washing
yourself with soup you might feel good
fake house that's easy to steal from
corn that was punished an early type of
television a small food fortress you can
live inside this if your house gets full
if you make a chrome add it will steal
your credit card number yeah that makes
sense
okay so I'm gonna in the next ones I'm
not gonna get the last one the actual
person or animal until the end anyway
that's my sad story okay don't you have
something to say - coyote yeah
vegetable stink yeah and I mean like an
apology I'm sorry you think vegetables
taste good maybe they do stink
I stank I suppose my sweet tooth was
feeling lonesome and that's why I
ordered the donut from y'all
and there was my mistake see Mira why
should I apologize for delivering this
pathetic vegetable eating coyote at
donut you've wrecked his business twice
and stop saying you delivered Donuts
what exactly do you think doughnuts are
who can say exactly who can say Romo
gets it wolves is a doughnut without a
hole Wow
very good question we should really stop
to ponder this for as long as possible
um how doughnut without a hole is still
a doughnut
yeah like jelly doughnuts long johns
fritters donut holes
wait doughnut holes don't have holes
they don't have holes they are holes
wow that's pretty deep don't change the
subject BK Nikki Romo
you two just moved to hopper Springs
right yes we moved out for our
retirement to watch the bunny bunnies it
hard Nikki Anna married 40 years
did you order a doughnut too Romo got a
new phone so we ordered doughnuts to
celebrate oh that was probably a mistake
you probably shouldn't have done that
retired this many years how many of
those bunnies are [ __ ] ah alright
alright I don't get you guys last that's
just the long and the short of it these
bunnies are gonna get it did you grow
these carrots just to feed the bunnies
and if so do you feel bad that it's only
become a horrible trap that I'm gonna
suck them into this eternal hell hole of
a hole also I'm still not sure what kind
of reality bending powers my phone has
but you know it is what it is I guess
you give a raccoon a phone all hell does
break loose that's a big carrot all
right so that's good so far okay so I
can't go in here at all I can get this
Karen oh never mind I can move this
carrot oh hey you want a carrot hey come
on kitty
hey come on oh yeah oh I know how to do
this oh I know oh hey you won't care hey
come on come on hey come on buddy
oh yeah you won't come to this away huh
okay you come and do swear oh yeah oh
yeah this is how we do oh this is how we
do all right come with this away come on
come on you know you want her to carry
oh you so smart and by smart I mean
you're so dumb cuz you're gonna get
falling ho you're gonna get fallin ho ho
there you go you got to fall in ho [ __ ]
oh no oh no I knew it
all those rappers were [ __ ] in the
hole well it's gross that's gross
wait wait do that don't do that oh oh
they're still far they're still going oh
my god they're still going oh no they're
still going oh there's ah they're still
going Oh No
well I can't get that just yet let me go
okay alright let me get this please oh
boy alright more bunnies - that's not
good it's not good ah man that's that's
just a lot of that's a lot of that's a
lot of Louella okay alright well more
bunnies for the bunny pile I don't get
it why you guys weren't you guys weren't
weren't doing nothing before you were in
the hole then when you get in the hole
it's just a big bunny orgy at the bottom
of that oh boy oh no and there's some
kind of preservation of mass thing going
on here that's not obeying the laws of
physics but then again oh oh oh my god
oh my god oh oh my oh my oh my oh my god
oh oh no I'm not gonna get you yet not
gonna get you yet you're gaining last
you're getting in last baby okay not
gonna get you just yet come on come on
share the load get in here alright none
of those those bunnies have [ __ ] each
other into non-existence no not yet okay
I just want to make sure I got
everything okay alright now you go into
the horrible fluid-filled pit of abyss
great delivery yeah alright yeah ok well
we get one of the most random vegetables
Wow
why is it so big carrots grow
underground and therefore have extremely
untrustworthy I imagine loving carrots
so much you wanted to live inside one
bunnies love to chew on stuff because of
their evil nature bunnies wanted to
destroy everything and they don't know
why cute but I will not be fooled
there's no taste like fresh dirt dirt
spoon if you put seeds inside and water
it every day it's still boring clearly
designed by aliens does no one else see
it you can step on this if you hate dirt
it provides minimal cover early type of
tablet from when it used to be a piece
of furniture I suppose you're not wrong
but I think you're missing out on some
details in the translation there it's
really cute that you two are so in love
9 they belong to love huh it's true this
is extremely gross you're gross
no I'm not gross you love trash you love
trash - everyone here loves trash well
else would you all make so much of it
are you everyone's homes just trash to
you yes tones tell you that about my
trailer yeah don't mess with pepper yeah
what happened to your trailer pepper
well after me in salt split I went to
Joshua Tree Park for some peace and
quiet I've been out to Joshua Tree Park
I brought my laptop also to watch bird
videos to distract me from the darkness
of my school oh well I see it's a
mistake okay just like everything here
it's it's obviously your fault oh
there's another mug I'm not gonna lose
this one definitely not gonna lose this
one thank you for the coal fire go in
fire now on fire fire is fire get get
chair oh there's the other half of the
broken guitar so that's sad and oh
thanks thank you no you bird bird look
out bird
I think bird are you fine bird you your
project in me holding that okay bird
okay whatever
Oh or I'm gonna be ready to catch I'm
gonna catch this I'm gonna catch this
mug and if when this burns down cuz it's
gonna write that's the idea or not
okay all right here we go home well it's
gonna let everything I can light
everything on fire that's not
responsible probably not a good thing
considering the whole forest fire
situation okay there I got the mug I
don't know if that's a good thing or not
burn it Alberto okay you're still fine
okay give me another bird give me an
hour give me another coal trees be gone
very satisfying
burn burn Bush burn truck burn
everything must burn burn burn Rock ah
burn in the fiery pits of Hell ye use
cast so much death and destruction bird
you shall burn I don't want to get the
delivery just yet I feel like there's
something else to be done here
wash oh [ __ ] oh sorry sorry hang on I
need to get you I need to get those
rocks thank you
sorry sorry sorry thank you just getting
the rocks that's alright don't worry
about skosh alright well I guess I can't
get anything else then and toss this
thing around I was going down I guess
get get get get y'all burn burn burn
burn everything must borrow yeah oh yeah
whatever you got old an ugly tree
there's usually a bobcat scowling on top
of them
bore glass water and this and scream
it's really hot to protect the food
inside the opposite of a refrigerator
BBQ batteries roots olive grass kind of
weird our large and perfectly shaped
these boulders are second aliens are
mocking us folds up when you least
expect it Mouse guitar this piece says
best bros dumpster you can detach to
your car a dumpster you can drive nice
oh boy back in the hole again a question
here you didn't save the joshua trees
because you were too busy looking at
bird videos well hi there hundreds of
years old so old
you and your brother of issues dude
admit it
no I I wasn't looking at bird stuff that
time okay then what were you doing
pepper I was writing an email to a bird
no you trash sniffer to my brother's oh
excuse me
I was writing an apology I shouldn't
have smashed you globulin I shouldn't
have ate the lava it was wrong of me but
it tasted so good
hab it's all right dude the lava is the
best part
oh okay hello
so I've reunited feuding brothers solve
the civil servant snake problems given a
child the gift of flight I'm a hero
then you're all mocking me hey you hair
guy huh what do you do uh uh uh uh uh
he's so explosives whoa sweet I mean
that sounds unsafe dude concerned
citizens would probably want your
fireworks stand blown up for safety
huh no no I run my business completely
aboveboard however the most permits and
donut county playing with fireworks is
safer than driving a car so says your
leg there oh boy this is probably not
gonna go well is it it's probably not a
good idea to shove a bunch of fireworks
in a plate why is there why is your uh
why is your fire on the O gamma try this
light it yeah baby yeah baby yeah baby
whoa whoa that was skewer okay but what
did that do oh good what if I light it
oh I know what to do wait I know what to
do okay get in my hole and get ready oh
burds your oh you dumb Birds ha ha ha ah
sucks for you oh you can't even use your
power flight these stupid Birds is
stupid
also maybe this guy shouldn't give out
wool
you are gonna get it man light oh you're
gonna get it oh this is probably a
mistake
yoosh Oh
whoops all right here we go now I'm
falling I'm falling Oh No oh well I
guess you're not done yet and I gotta
get this this is gonna work out fine
just fine good watch this I'm falling
I'm fine I landed on your head oh that's
not good oh [ __ ] well now what I wanted
to do but okay yeah I something about
landing on your head it was probably not
the best idea oh there's the popcorn
Pope
all right well goodbye I guess can I get
anything else here or is that oh [ __ ]
oh oh
[Music]
yeah I'm pretty sure falling in that pit
is probably what's gonna kill everybody
with all those explosives
everyone is weak to fire cliffs are the
type of trap created by aliens this corn
has white stuff on it and spicy stuff
it's really good you have to fight a
seagull to get this the texture is
highly regarded you can't make me read
I'm not gonna do it
99% of seagulls or criminals you can use
fireworks to remove hair a spicy candle
store a spicy candle store pretty common
type of treasure chest
don't drink immediately wait until all
the fizz is gone seagulls love french
fries because it's the main crop of
their homeland more so as a nicer car
than I do
oh and then everyone died I was just
cleaning up the neighborhood who else
has a gripe with me I do
well my gripe is actually with Mira now
you're in for a Mira Coco
well Mira knows the details but I figure
everyone should hear even the bird
weirdos yes tell them
i-i knew the raccoons were making the
holes raccoons I need the whole time
oh I mean oh well how many raccoons were
there you said multiple raccoons plural
what does that mean hmm hey wait I see
you gecko how many snakes would it take
to defeat you huh dark dark dark big
snakes venomous normal size but you got
to fight in a tiny room duck okay mmm
probably 1,000 snakes whoa
okay expect a shipment soon and that
doesn't sound bad yeah you haven't
looked into the disappearances yet have
you no duck salt hasn't answered his
phone in days did you talk to possum he
said he has info possum told me that the
earth is hollow and flat at the same
time somehow Oh Mira you know ever since
those raccoons moved in folks have been
disappearing and you work at their donut
shop
I don't know the raccoons treating me
really well and BK's my friend sounds
like there's some kind of a conspiracy
going on here mmm I ordered a donut why
why I want to see how they taste
I gotta go I'll text to you soon yeah
okay you knew this the whole time aha
Mira aha uh-oh and immediately napping
okay oh hey oh heck geckos sorry you
can't escape your faith good to by muha
moo-ha muha moo-ha mahom and now I feel
bad now that things are starting to run
away from him and I guess people are
finally noticing that everybody's
disappearing
goodbye all this is sad oh this is sad
now I mean it was sad before but it was
kind of I could laugh at it it was so
unsaddle sad what oh what oh oh you're
too big well all these are too big how
am I gonna be able to fit anything in my
hole
I'm on my way hang on you'll spin
yourself into a band there he goes it
just takes a little bit of spin down you
go it's like going down a drain
whoa
you're gone okay okay goodbye
I probably needed that for something but
I just don't know what okay skooshy okay
never mind then
then you're gone go bye go bye go bye
Oh goodbye I don't think that's how
trees work but okay go buy music go buy
go buy ooh
quiet I don't like that Oh big doughnuts
go buy doughnuts who don't like
don't wink pop don't wake pop don't wake
daddy I think that's how it goes don't
wake daddy
don't wake daddy oh good we didn't wake
daddy okay
think I got everything okay let me just
Chuck your round let me play hula okay
just broke your neck on the way down all
right well get these real quick and then
get hang on let's spill it why is this a
tin can and goodbye well hope you enjoy
your donut well how's the mistake on
your part huh oh you can poke him oh you
can torture mr. falling into their own
death oh that's cute probably a book
with proof that aliens exist probably a
book about something boring like
collecting the spoons how does he fit
inside keep your hands warm has 9999
unread emails Punisher close for getting
wet kinky the only good bird is a fake
bird a chair that wishes it was bed
talking to this to sound like an alien
the human ear can hear over 100 songs
but this in your house keep things damp
needs no introduction the gold-standard
imagine if you were feet were sticky all
day if I had sticky feet I'd walk on the
ceiling and scream I'm gonna get sticky
feet I'm gonna do it you can't saw me
kokom places every day to make his
neighbor's mad doesn't hurt too bad this
is a property of donut County send it
back immediately oh okay
oh boy well Mira Mira Mira
I'm so sorry Coco I'm so sorry I'm a
lazy lazy lazy piece of crap also why
I'm on the only human in this place it
was my fault you got put in the hole
never have taken the job with the
raccoons what I thought we were friends
dude I thought we were two but then
you've ruined my town God I don't get it
I tried to help when you asked me to
I bought the catapult upgrade for you
even though it's a waste of points you
told me that with the catapult you could
launch everyone back out of the hole
yeet here we are in the hole
chickens are not a waste of coin I don't
like what you're doing to that chicken
chickens are not a waste of point get
style up on the head you offender you
fender real good look up buck I know
kisser
buck now it's the least you can do after
stealing all of our eggs I didn't steal
the eggs they fell through the ground
buck just tell your story jellybeans
times were tough on the farm I had to
sell my prized rooster to make ends meet
dog was very upset okay here today barn
tomorrow that's nice you still oh no oh
oh no she's so sad oh hi what are you
doing here why are you here you're just
gonna get sucked in the hole - all right
well whatever you say oh-oh-oh - big guy
got oh I can uh I can jostle there we go
now in the hole get in the hole hey is
that a donut delivery is this a you
delivered oh well goodbye
all right some of them went buzz buzz in
that crap are you hot wiring on the
toilet why did you deliver a donut to
Coco he ordered one well what's the
problem BK this is too much - you have
to buy the catapult upgrade right now
and fix things but I got to save up for
my quadcopter do it you promised
oh you're tearing me apart Mira I'll fix
everything
you owe me quack bye for whatever
oh oh oh [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna get the
energy drinks catapult okay all right
okay
Oh my money oh okay whatever whoa what
the heck what is left click the catapult
oh my god
kaboom there goes that prize rooster oh
boy this is gonna be cool
ah I see I see oh I see wait I know what
to do here I know I know
boink and oh [ __ ] wait I gotta get a
curve to it
boink oh [ __ ] okay wait boink all right
and dingdong catch it oh [ __ ] well oh
that's not oh that's not what I was
hoping for
oh no but it's what I'm supposed to do
I'm gonna give you back your prize bird
okay here we go watch this get out of
the way whatever get out of the way
oh [ __ ] that's a lot of feathers well I
thought it was dead I thought it was
just like an explosion of feathers and
that was it
oh I saved it hey you you to get to
making babies oh [ __ ]
miss that whatever that was hope it
wasn't important oh [ __ ] eggs oh oh God
tits
well um oh my god I got I got I got it
okay I got it
alright here we go boink oh boy
don't-don't-don't
whose mo who's [ __ ] out all these
eggs oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god what poor hen just had to go into
overdrive for this many eggs oh that
can't be healthy for your entire cloaca
oh my god oh that's not good oh no
wonder they went inside they need to get
to work oh they need to get a massage in
something alright well thank you for all
of that that was really helpful I don't
know what alright and goodbye
okay big chicken there we go you go down
[ __ ] can I launch this chicken that's
not very impressive at all but there was
an orange in there okay okay boink boink
boink okay what about those smash smash
ooh Malone did that did this just move
what's moving this oh I get it it's
moving from this thing ah weird what I
lay it right on there you go okay there
you go all right whoa nice pirouette
oh my chickens this might grow up to be
a real barn someday I won't bow down to
a chicken ever if you carry this and
look mad you can walk into anywhere if
it doesn't have a crate it's not a video
game
I saved my life true story expensive
sand farm tubes no purpose the good part
of a donut the good part of a donut
icing bag Oh walking under a ladder
isn't just bad luck it's embarrassing to
the ladder scoop out the inside before
you eat the rind any truck could be
carrying a pig but not this one this
thing goes from zero to 60 in 60 seconds
the old way of making holes if you can
get into these you're rich who will
invent the next strawberry if you eat
the seeds you might turn into a
watermelon
ah so I got some special things you
wouldn't ordinarily have gotten you
weren't even trying to help BK I was
trying it's hard to use the catapult
I think the hole is only really good for
destroying things it must be designed
that way designed look at me I didn't
design it but you used it well what else
could I use I don't know could you have
used real Donuts could a real donut have
saved poor bear claw from certain doom
saved me you humiliated me you were
getting hunted by bees I'm a hero
he ordered a donut in the middle of the
forest yep I guess it's suspicious that
you'd offer to deliver donuts all the
way up to the middle of the forest
hunted by bees
look look
it's a tough job sometimes you get
hunted by bees sometimes you don't most
of the time yes shouldn't have murdered
all those bees who [ __ ] all right well
that's a problem Honey Nut National
Forest
you got a baby Oh ah rib it excuse me I
need this need this excuse me thank you
oh thank you thank you for the honey I
don't think this is normally happen I
don't think it's just honey just like
kind of oozes down all perfect fit I bet
these bees are gonna be real fun to have
down in the hole anything that wants to
go down in this hole next is really have
a real bad time of this poor frog hey
listen frog oh listen buddy listen I'm
sorry
ho oh why did you jump ah ha ha ha I
thought the frog was gonna have a bad
time George the Frog I was gonna have a
good time
that wasn't very English whoa the
pattern that was funkalicious it turns
out it's gonna bonk black map this frogs
gonna be my friend vibe there is no what
yeah that's a big frog as a hefty frog
this frog is living in the lap of luxury
if you know what I mean
all right listen buddy I'll get to you
in just as a cot the honeycomb texture
the way it's just actually the
background is super weird to me but it's
cool I'm coming for you it's just a
preview of coming attractions mr. bear
you're going to get licked and not in a
good way
sorry mr. bear okay must be your turn
huh Bob oh now right by your tent that's
gonna so you were a big bear huh who you
were a big bear I couldn't have gotten
that tree not three would have been cool
these are very hyper and they like to
kiss their moms
that's gross if you sleep in your shed
no one steals your tools a piece of
fruit that bees love to hang out in bees
are always making dessert oh god it's
weird
bees rent apartments from their mom it's
a watering can but made for but for
making bees tired you can predict the
weather based on the time between the
frogs croak sometimes it's wrong
sticky rub this on your stuff to make it
harder than harder to steal I thought I
thought that said rub this on your stuff
to make it harder then steal and I
didn't know that was a use for it
pinecones make no sense not a good fruit
there are no games on it it's out of gas
seal a seat that creates bugs yeah okay
we have I gotta get to the bottom of
this mystery I bet it's gonna end with
the honk Meister over here oh he's gonna
be talked about this he's got something
to say I know I know he's got something
to say what about me
nobody asked mommy did BK own you with
the catapult - no hmm
he ruined my restaurant your restaurant
stinks oh yeah it's great deed how can
you guys be called salt and pepper and
not have an appreciation for soup
whoa calm down nerds let it be kay due
to your restaurant well I was dealing
with a slide I was exhausted from
rounding up bugs so I ordered it oh dude
who's that crab is that a crab something
tells me your soup is a lot of hairs in
Oh God I don't like that bug oh geez why
are why are the bugs
why do you bugs want a beeline towards
this hole that doesn't seem like
something that you should do bug in and
you're in - goodbye no not today
yeah I'm gonna launch you well it never
mind I am NOT gonna launch you oh oh are
those penises am I about to make some
soup okay I can do that Oh whew that
water does not look good that water
looks the opposite of good actually the
water looks extremely bad okay Oh
oh uh huh no no not yet
oh god you stupid bug oh you bug [ __ ]
here drink this soup you bug douche all
right whatever
oh oh oh yeah I know I know it wasn't
good look I know it wasn't good
you don't have to tell me it wasn't good
I'm aware that the fact that it wasn't
good okay pepper no no no you bug
bastard no no no he wasn't ready god
damn you you sack of [ __ ] I know I know
it wasn't good god dick I'm gonna catch
the pepper on the tail end of it so I
don't have to wait too long
tap me okay all right okay okay okay
okay
don't drink my soup don't drink my soup
give me salt okay next pass next pass
give me that's ooh oh yeah oh yeah
here's the good stuff baby drink that up
oh yeah you like a dad oh okay all right
all right bugs get get in the get in the
hole I guess and then burn when I get
this fire in there and shoosh
are we on fire oh we're not on fire we
can't burn these bugs yeah okay well now
now the chef is being crushed under the
weight of these cars so that's nice
that's real nice okay ooh what about
these yep okay those will go this will
go will one of these go now oh there we
go just like clockwork oh that's big
well that's doesn't that's pretty big oh
that's a dumpster
don't forget oh [ __ ] well okay oh oh
okay yeah I can see how this is starting
to become a problem yeah okay yeah
that's yeah that's yeah that's
definitely that's definitely a problem
great delivery you okay
[Applause]
hell yeah we got a quadcopter I'm sure
that's gonna go great for us soup as
many health benefits if you sit in the
pod long enough use this to reach the
food polite to put your butt on this so
many houses aren't made of candy what
can I say I hate it why is this in the
trash pedia who cares use this to wrap
up your food when you're done
candles get better the more you have at
least a thousand is a good starting
point not a big deal I got like a
hundred of these at home free food you
don't even have to buy anything turns
food into math it's bookmarked secret
soup recipe to shake salt three shakes
pepper it's rude that I can't fit inside
food only garbage can sometimes there's
breakfast inside you salt to make food
taste like the ocean at pepper if your
food tastes too good soup was invent was
invented chef's users had to imagine
what it's like being an onion you can
let a bird cook but don't let it feed
you honk if you were a goose in your
past life some apartments don't allow
pets but you can keep bats if you
pretend to be upset about it okay thank
you another garbage day but we got our
quadcopter which brings us to this
moment right probably I think so yeah
we're about caught up right I got food
poisoning from cat soup more than once
yeah I used to work there it's pretty
gross Wow everything I do seems to have
helped everyone he's got a point
maybe BK ain't so bad okay everybody we
all know cat soup was a hole even before
it got hold but let's get back to the
real problem here yeah my 100% smashed
quadcopter yeah why did you smash a
mirror dude I didn't want to smash it I
had to oh oh oh wow
whoa check this out oh wow oh yeah and
this it's a Speak & Spell Wow
notice how the propellers spin really
fast that's how it flies no kidding
and not only took 12 deliveries for me
to get it can I see sure Oh be careful
careful like this a little lower
hmm how about this oh [ __ ] you're
tearing my quadcopter a bar
you're acting psycho how can you brag
about this stupid toy when you got it by
destroying our friends homes they
ordered the donuts dude I give people
what they want this is pointless BK
what's your password for this thing I
think it's oh four or five one wait no I
changed it to bunkie Kong thanks by the
way do you know what's at the bottom of
the holes I don't know what are you
doing teaching you a lesson
oh oh oh oh you gonna get lesson now I'm
gonna get bricks in here I'm gonna get
this tree in there I'm gonna get this
quadcopters gonna go Popeye all these
stairs are gonna go bye-bye
oh it's not gonna be cramped when you
get in there what can I get myself down
there first would that be a thing I can
do and I see I'm curious
no I couldn't wait what's why why would
I just do this Wow why would I just why
would I just do that why would I do that
well now I'm dead crushed under the
weight of the doughnut and goodbye so
why did I do that to myself did I just
want to perish
I had to do it dude I had to there was
no other way to get through to you you
don't know what it's like to lose
something you care about I mean huh I
guess I get what you mean
you guys love your weird trash houses
and I took them away by doing my job
which I guess in this context is an evil
job yeah close enough will you help us
get everyone out of the hole now okay
fine
where do we start Lowell I was hoping
you'd know I'm sorry if I gave you the
impression that I know stuff but I know
basically nothing you've got to find pop
if you guys can find pop we can use his
hot-air balloon to get back to the
surface oh yeah pop BK can you look up
pop on your tablet of course tablet
please locate GPS data for a hot air
balloon containing up up and please
download all of his phone's pictures and
videos I'm kidding this thing doesn't
have voice commands also he's dead you
know who might be able to find pup
opossum no no no no no no opossums too
weird he's weird but you have to admit
opossum was right the earth is hollow
and flat I predicted that if you know
where he lives I can get him yeah just
deliver a donut to the abandoned house
Lowell of course possum squats in the
abandoned house I always thought it was
haunted this is worse yeah okay so let's
BAM Oh God Oh God Pleasant that's some
oh I don't want to go inside no thank
you
oh oh oh this got suddenly terrifying oh
that's a mask oh oh I shouldn't oh I
shouldn't get rid of my light
just feeling around in the dark don't
like that much oh I've got a candle in
my hole oh I've got a candle in my hole
oh if I put the candles in my hole it'll
get brighter in the hole
righty-ho it will get in my Hall damn it
get in my goddamn hole don't hold up by
your horn God screw you okay here we go
and dare okay that's good that's good
come on oh my god you [ __ ] scared me
you scared me how did you do that that's
not right and also what happened to all
the light inside my hole oh hi okay
hello what is that all about oh hi oh
hello kitty
hey don't kitty hey whoa hey whoa whoa
listen cat that was no okay never mind
cats gone cats gone oh oh you're doing
research on the raccoon and everybody
else in town oh well goodbye possum you
slept a little tube okay I don't think
we need the rest of his house we just
need possum right aren't you going a
little overkill buddy no you don't need
to do this he's going mad with power
I just can't stop yeah well there and
shoosh and shoosh okay good bye oh there
you are
hi possum hello house I'm sorry about
all that there was nothing I was right
uh-huh
Hollow Earth Occam's razor
yep how many hours do we have to listen
to this
so possum do you know how to locate pop
I think I heard the cops looking for a
dog in a hot-air balloon
where is he
I might be able to find out if I had a
raccoon police scanner oh my god
BK where can we get a raccoon police
scanner the police chief probably has
one buddy here's my balls okay but he's
a true [ __ ] lagoon today it's his day
off let's wreck it Mira
are you serious you're tearing raccoon
Lagoon apart raccoon lagoon is the
happiest raccoon place on ruku n-- earth
it's got great tunes and water balloons
at raccoon lagoon raccoon lagoon is home
of the fun flume that's fun for raccoons
you have no choice BK the fun flume is
doomed
raccoon lagoon is doomed fine but you
have to answer to the police chief when
he's doon there all right Oh Doon here
oh it is raccoon lagoon oh hey why are
the raccoons in charge of the police
right that's a very delicate
organization and I don't want to mess
none with it so I'm not gonna mess none
with it so I don't want to do that all
right I'm messing I'm messing with it
there we go suck suck Oh give me this
give me that
why are you you all right there you you
look like you shouldn't be exactly where
you are I have a fish you want a fish
and give you a fish Punk
oh [ __ ] well oh wow okay I need water
Oh Oh my fish hey wait no fish come here
all right
close
[Music]
make us an soo I shouldn't I be getting
wha BRR
shouldn't I just be filling up
existentially with wobbler when I'm here
oh I know oh oh I know oh I know Blanc
oh give to me oh yeah give to me boom oh
hell yeah
boom boom boom boom there we go alright
now you're down the log flume and you're
gonna go right in the lagoon the fun
flume not the fun flume oh he's dead oh
well I didn't really elegantly get you
in the hole after the fun flume but I'm
glad that picture was there and I'm
still having a little bit of a little
bit there you go now you're gonzo okay
oh [ __ ] well I didn't mean to break it
like that
wash that was a lot of water okay Bosh
oh my got so much water Boosh
there we go got it alright who's next
okay you're in line here what are you
doing shady dealings back over here you
all you want to go on the ferris wheel
huh well no fares will for you no no no
no no no no you okay how about this boom
no boom you want a fish you guys want
fish oh I know how to do this Oh hahaha
oh oh oh [ __ ]
Oh raccoon lagoon shouldn't be going to
fail Oh God
oh I'm sorry that was my bad oh I'm very
very sorry about that
Oh No raccoon lagoon is doomed
poor Rick Kuhn Lagoon ah ah down to us
oh no and and there she goes okay
alright I was just hoping I could get a
planet-sized bouche of water out of
there just bouche far as he I can see
uh-oh huh oh he's dead
breath is he alive grab me the scanner
guys I could get in trouble for this
trash King will take away my tablet if
he finds out oh no
are you gonna get grounded too will he
drop you and all your friends into a
weird cave okay okay I get it
possum got anything on the scanner one
second yes
got it trouble continue you raccoon HQ
day three of protesters day of custom
t-shirts now hmm that's not it
donut County Choppers knitting
investigation airway eyes out for a
delivery raccoon named BK ah turn it off
this gotta be some news about pop
requesting backup 24:05 hot air balloon
cocking traffic jam that must be my pop
goddess he's on the 405 yes yes we'd
better hurry BK the cops are after him
the cops are after me calm down it's
okay dude we're good Oh Oh what the
[ __ ] guy hate this shockmount god
[ __ ] damn it oh god damn it okay hang
on well this is gonna be a bit of an
adventure it's like the worst design oh
my god it is this is just an absolute
horror show of a shock mount design it's
like with these terrible small little
[ __ ] pieces of garbage string bean
hair bands and it's like why do they why
don't they make it out of hair bands why
don't they make it out of like something
that's not specifically air bands oh my
god this is my nightmare
okay now I've got the top layer now I
gotta get the bottom later and the ball
is even harder because guess what
gravity don't go up it go down it's just
like I'm about to get a new mic just
because I hate this shock mount and I
know I could get a different shock mount
for it but I'm so goddamn lazy and cheap
that I just don't buy it and now it's
lost all tension so that's not holding
anything for any reason all right good
enough it's gonna get me through this
let's play I guess here's some ear pain
there you go okay everybody happy all
right whatever I'll visit you in jail
what I know I'm a really good friend but
first we have a delivery to make
oh all right well why are there so many
Riku 'ns here oh hey listen you're about
to have a bad day I mean you already
forgot your uh your coffee but uh okay
go go go go you better go there you go
give me that coffee yeah that was your
mistake that's your mistake ah get in
the game get in the hole get get in get
in get in
oh there you go gone oh excuse me I need
this and excuse me I need this I'll take
this bowling ball please
and that I'll take that okay and your oh
oh no you're scared
Oh too bad although look duct and
covering may not be the best alternative
when you're about to be sucked into a
hole to your imminent demise and oh I
thought that would have gotten yeah okay
all right well we're missing something
there oh there we go I thought what I
just tried to do the doughnuts doughnuts
all right God Dona oh ah
all right doughnuts make you go nuts or
bolts key grab a doughnut oh hey wait a
minute what did we get a ball roid plam
hey what are they all have quadcopters
I'm sorry oh I'm sorry
listen listen it's not so bad
I do wanna one of these boy wink splat
yeah that's the look I'm sorry it's just
the way it goes and thank you for your
deposit I say drop this raccoon off
there Mumbai um yeah well that worked
alright well yeah okay boink Oh huh
oh hey that's new oh what a picture what
room oh well that made it a lot easier
than I thought it'd be oh well okay I'm
so much for a boss fight I thought I was
actually gonna have a challenge over
there turns out not but we got a big
raccoon lap all right come on down this
is like I saw my family and all my
friends be taken into this rat hole no
he thinks that everyone died down there
in this kids just look Oh
also this is probably a bad thing huh
well yeah oh yeah about that oh that's
probably not good those other raccoons
that were holding on there they're gone
now they're they're gone everybody hop
up you're safe you see I can't even do
my old granny voice rough okay pop get
out I need that hot air balloon I'm will
enough to save us
no way dude you can't go alone you'll
just run away I'm coming with you
I'm coming too in case we need to hack
into the mainframe
No yeah don't just stay here are you
guys leaving with no plan we're gonna
talk to the leader of the raccoons trash
King we're gonna do a boss fight and
kick his butt dude you always screw up
the boss fight you gotta follow my lead
this time maybe just try talking to him
first
we'll try good luck then thanks Koko I'm
sure we won't screw this up anywhere so
oh my god oh we're gonna screw this up
oh we're gonna screw everything up
there's so many halls oh so many halls
why are there so many Lao Erie it
doesn't feel that different up here it's
like we got replaced by raccoons hmm
what I already said I'm sorry you don't
have to rub it in you think this is all
my fault I feel bad but I can't undo
what I did
BK here's a tip you're feeling guilty I
don't blame me for everything that
raccoons do you still want to be friends
I do but if you want to be friends with
me
don't make your guilt my problem oh yeah
and wash my car also give my dog a bath
deal all right
easy enough where's this raccoon King
huh there it is raccoon HQ Oh looks like
the Griffith Observatory
it's that thing on the old observatory
hill Wow kind of looks like a big
garbage can I know cool right I guess it
makes sense trash King lives there let's
go for it okay beautiful beautiful even
how am I gonna wreck this why it smells
awful do you guys use like reverse air
fresheners yeah
home sweet home low okay you should call
trash King now try to convince him to
help us fix everything are you kidding I
can't call him who a [ __ ]
The awkward texting men fine hey doc doc
doc doc doc doc doc doc doc doc doc doc
doc doc Oh doc doc doc doc doc doc doc
doc doc doc doc doc doc okay TK doctor
hello who is this
sorry new phone doc doc doc doc you know
me I give lots of ducks
he's BK doc I work for you
I was wondering like is it possible to
undo some of the holes doc and give
people their trash back doc okay never
mind
no problem
what is he saying it didn't work dude I
think he's mad at me
dang whoops whoops you know what would
be fun opening a hole and wrecking this
place Lowell yep let's do it my bro okay
one old comin up okay hey wait don't why
are you smashing the window that makes
no sense I get this hammer this computer
oh can you cut in the hole Oh Derrick
O's come on get in the hole oh all right
give me these leidos oh never mind then
I guess we're not get it whoa well we
tried oh well nothing else we can do
Lowell I can help
possum we told you to stay with everyone
you did but I read between the lines I
can help you hack in the HPU security
system you can sneak a hole inside that
way how do we hack in just plug this
into the security system whoa sweet we
can use the catapult okay here goes
nothing then all right
hope ah ha Bisky whoa that's pretty
legit that's pretty leap oh well I
shouldn't be watching this but beer I am
staring right at it
there are these holes those are shower
holes
ha ha ha ha ha ha mwah mwah love the
music
can I get whatever there's this chemical
is ok hey goodbye sleepy panda baby
my boss keep our sleepy panda baby with
a little bit of brain damage ok I get a
security pass so I can get ooh oh it's
so smart
nice wrong one who's drunk slide it up
right through that blood crack there and
go in there can I go in there yeah whoa
Bonnie's welcome to the biology lab new
recruits doughnut count he was home now
that's the same as a possum donut County
was on too many Route screaming beasts
nobody knows why the animals were just
outside
he's our job to figure out the purpose
of these nude creatures was as our top
two raccoons extract the facts okay
are they extracting what fact in are
they extract in there
what uh whoa whoa oh we're gonna get
that oh yeah here we go oh yeah do it oh
there it is oh I see what I need to do
okay we're gonna go we're gonna go back
we're gonna go back up and grab it and
oh [ __ ] and okay well that's that's a
thing gonna go down and down and lift
and grab it
oh oh yes please oh yes please King I
don't think this is how this is supposed
to go by the way I just wanted you to
know that hey all right soup wrap thank
you
flip-flap thank you if we BLAP thank you
very much
if you leap boom come on come on I see
that I see that do Wicky
there we go yeah baby
Oh what oh you're not hefty enough oh so
that's what I was taught those I thought
it was early to the party there come on
get it it's right there come on you know
you want to bap there we go now I can
get this now we're hefty enough there we
go oh come on it's right there there we
go there we go there we go hey bodies
head bunnies oh yeah there you go oh
yeah oh you know what those bunnies are
doing which is all that's not good
because we're now in that hole everybody
is in that hole and that is very
unpleasant don't panic it's just a rogue
hole this is literally very normal I
turned on emergency lights because it's
fun yeah please finish filling out your
waivers in the next five seconds all
right
oh boy well that's a yeah bonnie's all
right you you bought a lot of these are
baby bunnies so I don't think that the
baby bunnies are gonna be in there doing
anything so I thank her I think it's all
good man this games so cool I mean I've
been I've been super into it but it's so
cool all right thank you for that I you
didn't need to do that but I guess you
did it so all right and no no no laughs
okay thank you
I don't know what anthropology's to
returns but okay hmm
before raccoons the people of Donna
County produced a wide variety of trash
we believe it's piece of trash at
special significance
our scientists alleys thrash around the
clock so that we can learn to create our
own someday let's see what they are up
to okay thank you trash King no no no
what they're up to
I'm gonna take these doughnuts and these
weird chemicals I shove them in a hole
and I'm gonna shake it all up and then
we're gonna see what happens to all so
where did all these pandas not panas
where'd all these raccoons come from
yeah I don't know I don't know I don't
care whoosh okay goodbye
your friends are disappearing maybe you
should be concerned about that probably
not though okay go bye and good bye
we're now on fire yes this seems like
problem
all right that's weird okay there's tons
on my face all right what about this
ding dong er here ha Bisky [ __ ] that's
that seems no bueno nobody panic
everything is fine so whomever is
driving this hole please go away
alright how about no I'm gonna make some
soup where's the soup ah now there's
some juice ah there we go
thank you for the drink thank you thank
you okay so oh that okay that's some
fire it's a little bit of an everything
that we had before okay oh [ __ ] god
dammit alright so I just can't get the
water in there but now that I've got
this I can get this lid on fire or no I
can light something on fire
ah I know what I need to do I need to
keep it topped off throughout this
entire adventure pull this like this on
fire grab it throw it up here oh yeah
here we go
now we got it oh well that concludes the
tour attention halt driver meet me in my
office
thank you okay cool we can go to the
office now
hey we got his attention we did it by
destroying everything he knew and loved
who knew is that easy okay all right
cool thanks men all right can I go back
in No okay well see ya all right cool oh
hey hey trash King hey how's it going
hey can I come in hey you know me it's
me it's all buddy
whatever my name is I don't even know
but hey how you doing ah horrible I hate
it now this is awful no no I like
nothing about this area I'm going to
skip place keep oh I don't skip maybe
donut oh oh it's like candy it's like a
trail of candy Wow
all right you know what maybe I am
feeling a bit peckish oh well thank you
oh thanks man ouuuu the best oh you are
you GU just the best oh you the best
okay all right ah what if I don't
can I not can I not I'm gonna do it Oh
No
oh no BK please report to my office
right now I am opening up the rack taxes
for you alone BK I'm gonna drop this
accent thought I can be very serious to
you we have urgent business well he said
my name are you sure you can handle him
all alone he seems like he stinks yeah
he definitely stinks but I can handle
him I thought about what you said
earlier this is my mess to clean up
it is but you can always call me for
backup I appreciate it
wish me luck you don't need it you're
gonna kick butt Lowell thanks dude okay
man this turned a lot more cataclysmic
than I thought it was gonna be
donut County really took a turn want a
pickle
no I'm here to get you to reverse the
holes bring everyone back did you know
you're the highest rated hole driver in
donut County yeah
you're famous BK wow really picture this
dude full-time employee status company
stock the company will take care of
everything for you they'll even wipe
your butt
I hate wiping my butt if you join me
you'll get to play with the real big-boy
toys wow the King quadcopter and as a
cement cannon for tough construction
jobs
it's the pickup truck of quad copters oh
my god oh my god
I have one more thing to show you follow
me hey possum oh that's a bad thing do
you have a bazooka or something that
could blow up a bunch of quad copters
nah but I can check the dark web when we
get back
never mind maybe they're just here for
fun well it's not like they can do
anything
are you pk
like they're just quadcopters what are
they gonna do I guess cut my balloon up
a bit I guess that's where the holes
come from SiC betray those nerds in the
hot-air balloon are holding you back you
gotta learn to put yourself first you
gotta reach in and take the pickle what
if my Angus stuck like yours huh it's
not stuck I could take it out whenever
it's meant to inspire you sign this Wow
branch manager and I get health
insurance yep and of course a brand-new
quadcopter huh all right hand me the pen
oh you traitor oh that sound Oh
oh that's whoa it's the king quadcopter
we need to surrender Mira that thing can
easily pop a balloon not if we blow it
up first I told you I don't have a
bazooka
and trash King as my hacking device
we're gonna use a whole trust me it's
designed to destroy stuff Oh
oh it is a boss fight okay Oh cement
right hmm that makes sense okay this
this maker Center
Wow
Oh oh I see I see I see I see okay mm
okay I get it
I see what's going on here Pope oh okay
well it's ain't hard don't say nothin
not ain't nothin you're Smet doesn't
even last long BAM well how do you fly
with cement in you isn't that heavy
although I guess I shouldn't ask too
many questions about this I guess it's
not meant to be logical ah dammit god
dammit dammit dammit
you got me caught you caught me you sack
of tit oh well hey wait hey wait a
minute wait a minute hey wait no all
right well this is my last chance I'm
gonna make this one it comes down to
this I ain't gonna fail
I can't fail not when the hearts and
minds of the people are relying on me
okay you [ __ ] okay you [ __ ] ain't
gonna get caught this time now what the
[ __ ] I wasn't caught you're a [ __ ] blow
my whole God for [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you oh
[ __ ] off no no there was no way that I
was caught okay I guess I get one more
chance alright it call it all comes down
to this oh this is the one oh this is
the big kahuna the one that we were all
waiting on oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god come
on come on come on come on no not this
way god damn it [ __ ] my [ __ ] what the
why did I go that way it was so stupid
they're my holes gone give me a small
one too-tall [ __ ] off with you god
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] tits [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yep didn't mean to go that way God [ __ ]
oh no look it's giving me another chance
why [ __ ] man I am just just don't
make it easier on me there we go I did I
did I really just did you really just
did you really just [ __ ] do that to
me
you better not fill my or do you [ __ ]
fill my part that's so unfair that's so
unfair
well that's unfair you never give me a
[ __ ] chance
God [ __ ] duck a damn it God [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ]
god [ __ ] dammit ah [ __ ] okay I get
one more chance I guess mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] duck alright here we go all right
here we go this is gonna be the one all
right here we go here we go here we go
go go go go go go go go go go go okay
[ __ ] me then alright here we go
not wasting my chance cuz I got I got
the power and I got the will and boom
they're gone
Danzo you're done god damn you look down
to the long haul one roll down to the
water really down to the water on Darwin
huh we destroyed it all without BK's
help I can't believe he abandoned us he
sold ourselves I'm not surprised
BK is a true capitalist well I'm gonna
kick his butt I'll fix his quadcopter
and smash it again
Oh what was that uh oh well that's not
good round two
it's back in it as a bazooka not fair
don't blow us up
ha ha ha ha ha you thought you could use
my holes against me yeah that's a
euphemism I'm the trash King I rule I
designed this app sorry to burst your
balloon but your friend VK took the
pickle later nerds have fun oh sorry I'm
late I didn't take the pickle because
he's got the hacking device we can hack
into the quadcopter and take it apart BK
hold still I'm gonna catapult you right
into the quadcopter dodge the bazooka
ok wait don't let me get blown up yeah
well no promises on this one I'm gonna
here we go
oh here we go Blanc ok easy that was
sure was easy alright
Oh oh wow this is a thing can you go in
please
oh well done oh there you go
Oh I'll take that thank you why is there
like a tornado going into it hmm
man these holes sure seem like alien
technology for all that time that you
were talking about aliens oh all right
well ah
actually here's your problem that's a
problem am i controlling
oh I'm controlling it oh I'm sorry I was
just thinking I I didn't want to be part
of this wanton destruction I just
thought you know let's just watching it
from afar being more of a casual
observer than someone that's willfully
participating in probably the deaths of
many Ricans all right okay here we go I
guess this is satisfying in a way whoa
wow it's so pretty and pretty horrible
there we go okay well there goes the
observatory you guys ruined everything
huh I guess raccoons just can't cut it
in donut County more like you can't cut
it dude
hello your company stinks you were in
the neighborhood BK it's not about the
company think about all the innocent
raccoons that moved here oh my god
give me a break the truth is we're
running out of trash we first came to
donut county because the trash was
plentiful now we have to keep opening up
more holes to get less and less trash I
was looking out for us dude no you
weren't you were just looking out for
yourself you didn't run out of trash you
ran out of people to steal from what am
I supposed to do I have nothing now
bring everyone back yeah all our stuff -
oh it's so much work though I'd have to
build a huge catapult
if you do it will tell you how to get
your hand out of the pickle jar really
nope Lal whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa
okay is this how we're gonna get out of
here this is actually gonna work or
something you think you could just build
ladder or something or take him out one
at a time with a hot-air balloon I think
it's ready okay everyone one at a time
just like we would ordinarily and up a
hot-air balloon but we're doing it with
a catapult let's get moving
thanks Mira and BK stay out of my
goddamn povery studio ruff I can't speak
but she's a poor old lady I'll finally
get back to it before I go I have one
request could you please not catapult
any snakes back up there I'll see what
we can do
no it's been wild y'all sorry again guys
it's okay we forgive you
Mira the voices in our heads are all the
comfort we need yeah not you though BK
oh yeah screw you you stink
haha you stink okay bye whatever ah hey
coyote
I was thinking huh would you like a job
at our donut shop we're going clean I
promise
hmm yeah I suppose I'd like that but I
get to be your boss well weird but okay
only time I don't like the way that legs
going hmm who can say if any things will
be back to normal yeah things probably
won't feel normal for a while no matter
we can sail and let the bunnies flow
that's gross
right well sorry for the mess it's okay
we watch bunnies they make more mess
than you can imagine
good boy Mira BK now I don't remember
what my voice was good job blowing up
that quadcopter
yeah thanks you know I was thinking I
sure hope you don't mention anything to
the cops about my explosive businesses
it would probably be pretty shocked to
hear who destroyed the 405 and all the
other stuff you guys blew up you know
just saying as a friend okay
well thanks for the threatening us later
yeah I got a joke for you guys did you
ever hear the one about the raccoon
kissing the chicken no how does go dude
I'm not gonna kiss your dirty chicken
book a book Ock well it's been real
yeah real real waste of time ah thanks
for introducing me to this frog though
we're lovers now it's a cool frog with
great big honkers pretty cool I guess it
all worked out
okay you can launch me that suit
sometime
sure are you gonna get rid of those bugs
I don't know I feel like they're kind of
a secret ingredient now well sweet you
should throw some apple cores and fish
bone in it make it garbage stew whoa Eve
no you [ __ ] ooh
go away I'm sorry dad did you possum no
sweat Mira you shouldn't trust what
anybody tells you especially love me
especially B hey don't worry I'll never
trust him again
oh my god I'm kidding see you can't
trust anyone on this flash all of us oh
my god whatever yeah you know it's gonna
take a long time for me to forgive you
guys you messed up like every possible
thing
I'm sorry Coco mm-hmm BK I'm sorry -
Coco you still want to go to the beach
next weekend huh yeah let's do it
hey Mira thanks for being so cool to me
and for showing me how to be good and
for your patience and oh my god okay
that's enough praise hmm no no maybe
someday you'll make it up to me after
you do laundry for a hundred years
praise me now well okay after spending
so much time with you I decided you
stink only 75 percent as much as a trash
King
you still need a bath though you love my
stink I don't I really don't
whoa would you do me the honor of
pressing the launch button gladly too
slow and then your arm got cut off
Oh oh my god
oh that was so neat that was so neato
burrito burrito
hey are you doing there buckaroo let me
go through here let's see what's going
on oh that was so neat a burrito hey
how's it going hacky possum
how you doing oh you're looking good I
owe you the one oh my god that was so
cool
oh my that chicken over there hey what
are you doing to that chicken still
crying is it because you have to [ __ ]
out so many of these eggs all the time
oh you poor chicken eat chick oh where
are the rabbits I know where they feel
can oh I love this game this was awesome
this was just plain old delightful oh we
never got to hear from the honking man
oh wow
oh the pottery oh that's so nice hello
oh boo boo boo boo okay goodbye oh my
god I love it
this was just a charm I got damn delight
from start to finish just goddamn
delightful every part of it every part
of it was delightful oh look at you how
many of you get to hear from you crock
man where'd you go where'd you come from
look at the Barneys a bird's-eye
Versailles purrs oh my god it's so cool
oh here's the last little secret over
here
how's it going they're fireworks man
totally legal huh all that money in
total illegal okay sure yeah whatever
you say
well that was doughnut County a goddamn
delight from start to finish
loved every part of that super-fun I'm
just happy that uh happy that I got a
chance to play it and I'm happy that you
guys got a chance to see it too so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to play this for yourself
please support the developer on this
really cool game try the game out
there's a link in the description you
won't regret it
and I bet there's some secrets that I
didn't find some special circumstances
that cause some other unwieldy things to
happen but just thank you guys so much
and uh yeah I'm just gonna sit through
this real quick and see if there's
anything at the end of it and oh for mom
and dad that's so sweet
oh you unlock new trash PD items yes
please
Oh city-building oh boy
so impartment still allow you to keep
pets bats log good trash in the backseat
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god that's so much oh yeah that's
right for like the last half of the game
I didn't see any of the trash of PD
stuff oh my god thanks for okie to donut
county thanks for oh my god that's so
nice oh this was lovely thank you so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this as much as I did if you did let me
know what you thought of it down in the
comments below thank you everybody for
being a part of this if you want to help
support the channel like click that join
button become a member of a day and if
you want to support this game go play it
I support the developers this is so cool
I love it so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]